INTRO:
Nvidia is one of the most underrated mega
cap companies in the world.
While Nvidia is extremely popular within gaming
and tech circles, the average person is not
so familiar with the company.
This is quite surprising because unlike some
other background mega cap companies like TSMC
and ASML, much of Nvidia’s customer base
is everyday people.
Despite this, Nvidia was able to race towards
a trillion dollar valuation under the radar.
At the peak, Nvidia boasted a valuation of
$867 billion.
But, it looks like becoming a trillion dollar
company just wasn’t in the cards for Nvidia
at the time given that their stock has gotten
obliterated.
In fact, since their peak in November, Nvidia
has sold off a painful 55% which correlates
to a market cap loss of $480 billion.
By now, this is probably not even that surprising
given how bad the overall market is doing.
But, like all the other companies that have
sold off this much, Nvidia does have it’s
own set of shortfalls and concerns.
So, here’s why Nvidia is down $480 billion
and why it may be long journey back to the
top.
SEASONAL:
One of the biggest shortfalls of Nvidia’s
business is that they’ve somehow become
a seasonal business.
Now, this might sound a bit surprising given
that demand for their GPUs is rather constant
from companies and everyday people.
But, there’s also a third demographic that
you need to consider which is of course miners.
If you’re not familiar with cryptocurrency
mining, it’s basically a super computationally
intense process that validates crypto transactions.
The people who validate these transactions
are called miners and they get paid for each
block of transactions that they validate.
Now, miners don’t have to do anything manually,
but given the high computational requirements
to mine, they’re forced to buy extremely
powerful hardware.
And as you guess, one of their top choices
is Nvidia GPUs.
In the early days, miners didn’t really
influence the overall GPU market all the much
as they were a pretty small community.
But, as cryptocurrency becomes larger and
more people jump on board, it’s only natural
that the mining community has also gotten
quite large.
If miners were simply buying gpus on a regular
basis, this wouldn’t really be a problem.
But, the interest in mining is highly correlated
with the bitcoin market cycles which have
thus far been highly seasonal.
For example, let’s take a look at the 2017
Bitcoin cycle and compare it to Nvidia’s
net income.
As we can see, Ethereum which is what people
were predominantly mining with Nvidia gpus
peaked in early 2018.
This momentum along with the release of Nvidia’s
2000 series of gpus carried the company throughout
much of 2018.
But as the hype surrounding the new gpus settled
down and miners flocked the scene, Nvidia’s
net income got obliterated.
Within just two quarters, Nvidia’ net income
crashed 68% from $1.23 billion to $394 million.
It wasn’t till the last quarter of 2020
when Bitcoin returned to its all time high
that Nvidia’s net income also recovered.
Since then, Nvidia’s income has only gone
up, but as we saw in 2018, it’s takes about
a year for the crypto cycle to reflect in
Nvidia’s bottom line.
Also, Nvidia is supposed to release the 4000
series of gpus this year similar to the 2000
series in 2018, so that should help hold up
their income for some time.
But as we get into the end of this year and
especially the beginning of next year, the
weak crypto market will likely weigh down
on Nvidia’s income quite substantially.
PERMANENT SEPARATION:
Even if the crypto markets do recover within
the nest 12 months, it’s going to be difficult
for Nvidia to maintain their current numbers
because Nvidia and miners are slowly parting
ways.
From Nvidia’s side, they’ve been limiting
the performance of their GPUs if they’re
used for mining.
The goal with this limit is to mitigate the
demand from miners and make more gpus available
for everyone else.
Now of course, hackers have figured out ways
to bypass these limits, but that’s besides
the point.
The point is that Nvidia is finally taking
action to limit the number of GPUs that are
sold to miners.
This was something that Nvidia was previously
extremely reluctant to do for obvious reasons.
However, Nvidia has been switching their stance
likely because they've realized that in the
long term, they will lose the mining demographic
no matter what.
And when that happens, they want to ensure
that they have a strong core of gamers that
are still loyal to the brand.
But wait a minute, why will Nvidia lose out
on the mining demographic in the first place?
Well, the answer boils down to two reasons
starting with ASICs.
ASICs or application-specific integrated circuits
are hardware that are specifically built for
a given computational purpose which in our
case is mining.
In the early days, mining ASICs weren’t
that prevalent given that there wasn’t much
demand for them.
But, nowadays, full on companies like Bitmain
have built on just selling mining ASICs.
And given that mining ASICs are specifically
built for mining, they’re way better than
Nvidia’s gaming GPUs for mining.
Now, Nvidia has launched mining specific hardware,
so they might make a targetted move into the
crypto market.
But, the days of using gaming gpus for mining
are definitely coming to an end.
Something else to consider is that much of
the crypto market is trying move away from
mining altogether due to how wasteful the
process is.
Afterall, to mine, you have to buy loads of
expensive hardware and constantly burn mountains
of electricity to keep them running.
So, cryptos like Ethereum are trying to switch
to a proof of stake model from a proof of
work model.
Both of these models are rather complex, but
all you need to know is that the new method
does not require super powerful hardware.
The founder of ethereum, Vitalik Buterin,
has already been trying to make this switch
for years, and he may be trying for years
to come as well.
But at this point, it seems like a transition
to proof of stake not just for etherem but
cryptocurrencies as a whole is ineveitable.
And as crypto and Nvidia sever their ties,
there’s no question that Nvidia’s financials
will take a hit.
Now, it might seem like I’m overstating
Nvidia’s dependence on mining, but this
is not the case.
In fact, the SEC just fined Nvidia for not
disclosing how dependent they were on cypromining
to investors.
Considering this, declining demand from miners
is by far the biggest threat for Nvidia.
UNSUSTAINABLE PRICES:
Another major threat for Nvidia’s business
is their unsustainable price increases.
Over the past several years, Nvidia has enjoyed
extremely strong pricing power due to overwhelming
demand.
For one, miners are willing to pay way more
for Nvidia’s gpus than gamers because it’s
an investment for them, not just entertainment.
And secondly, the supply shortage and more
specifically the chip shortage has made it
imposible for Nvidia to keep up with demand.
This deadly combination has led to gpus selling
for unreal amounts on secondary markets.
Take the RTX 3090 for example.
The RTX 3090 launched with a sticker price
of $1500.
This itself is super expensive until you take
a look at how much these gpus are selling
for on secondary markets.
This listing for example comes in at an eyewatering
$4800 or over 3 times the launch price.
Now, given that this is the resale market,
Nvidia doesn’t actually make anything from
these ludicrous resale prices.
However, this has allowed Nvidia to substantially
raise the launch prices of their new gpus.
For example, in 2017, Nvidia’s flagship
GPU, the GTX 1080 TI, launched for $700.
Last year, Nvidia launched the 3000 series
equivalent, the 3080 TI, for $1200.
This means that Nvidia was able to raise prices
by 71% within a matter of 4 years, and that’s
not even considering their new additions.
You see, Nvidia had so much demand that they
decided to launch even higher end consumer
gpus called the 3090 and 3090 ti.
And the launch price of the 3090 ti is a whopping
$2000.
This means that Nvidia’s flagship consumer
gpu has risen from $700 to $2000 within 5
years.
Clearly, gpu prices have gotten way out of
hand and they’ve been like this for years
at this point.
But, eventually, things will cool down like
they always do and Nvidia will lose pricing
power.
I mean, even Apple had to reduce the launch
price of their iPhones with the iPhone 11.
And Apple had only raised the launch price
of their iphone by $100.
Nvidia is over here raising prices $500, so
it’s no wonder that investors are worried
about Nvidia's pricing power in the future.
UNSUSTAINABLE VALUATION:
It’s not just Nvidia’s customers that
have been willing to pay any price for their
gpus.
Till recently, Nvidia’s investors were also
willing to pay any price for Nvidia stock.
In fact, I don’t think it’s a stretch
to say that Nvidia had the richest valuation
on the entire stock market.
For example, if we take a look at their PE
ratio or their price to earnings ratio, they
were floating at 70 to 80 for much of 2020
and 2021.
For perspective, Apple is trading at a pe
ratio in the mid 20s and Micorosft is trading
at a pe ratio in the high 20s.
Now, this is not actually that bad when you
compare it to Tesla which peaked at a PE ratio
over 1000.
But, here’s the key difference.
Tesla was barely profitable with a net margin
of just 2.29% while Nvidia was at peak profitability
with a net margin of over 30%.
This means that Tesla’s PE ratio was super
skewed due to low profits while Nvidia’s
PE ratio wasn’t skewed at all.
And this becomes super clear when we compare
the price to sales ratio of the two companies.
Tesla’s PS ratio peaked at 23.75 while Nvidia’s
PS ratio ran all the way to 26.62.
Also, let’s not forget that Tesla is the
most hyped stock on the market.
But somehow, Nvidia was even more richly valued
despite having far inferior growth prospects.
Also, the recent sell off hasn’t made their
valuation that much better.
Nvidia still has a PE ratio of nearly 50 and
a market cap of $460 billion.
And thus far, Nvidia has only been reporting
stellar quarters.
Imagine if Nvidia has just one quarter of
stagnation or even a decline.
Their current valuation would just become
even less justified causing investors to sell
off the stock even further.
And don’t think that just because Nvidia
has already dropped 50% means that they can’t
drop much further because they definitely
can.
If mining demand doesn’t recover and the
overall market continues to sell off, Nvidia
can easily sell off 80-90% like it did during
the dotcom bust and the 2008 financial recession.
Really, you don’t even have to look that
far to realize how much Nvidia can drop.
Just take a look at Netflix or PayPal right
now.
FUTURE OF NVIDIA:
At the end of the day, Nvidia has been propped
up by a several factors for several years
now.
First you had the 2017 bitcoin bull run, then
there was the 2021 bitcoin bull run, and now
you have the supply shortage.
All of these factors have given Nvidia an
unprecedented amount of pricing power and
leverage which Nvidia has cleverly used to
maximize profits.
But, as these temporary boosts start to fade
away, the short term future of Nvidia is becoming
more and more uncertain.
Combine this with the fact that Nvidia was
already one of the richest valuations on the
market, and it becomes clear that Nvidia’s
50% sell off could just be the beginning of
something much more painful.
This isn’t to say that Nvidia is screwed
in the long term by any means though.
Nvidia produces the best gpus in the world
and they’ve diversified into several sectors
from machine learning to artificial intelligence.
So, Nvidia is by no means going anywhere.
But, it’s very likely that we start to see
declines in Nvidia’s financials as the GPU
market finally cools down and miners move
away from gaming gpus.
But if we look past that, I think it’s just
a matter of time until their dominant position
and massive investments pay off and Nvidia
reaches a trillion dollar valuation.
But that’s just what I think.
Do you guys have an Nvidia gpu?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you can’t wait for
gpu prices to finally cool down.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.